hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast precision medicine two
point O impact requires data
collaboration champions presented by
David Shaywitz MD ph.d excited to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by labyrinth to learn more
about lab roots please visit www.fcn I'm
jus T O'Rourke of lab weeks and I'll be
your moderator for today's event this is
an educational webinar and thus offers
free continuing education credits after
the webinar is over and to get your
credits click on the button located in
the bottom left hand corner of your web
page before we begin I would like to
remind everyone this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
type your question into the box if it
appears on the screen will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice that you'll be viewing the
presentation in the slide window too
large the window just click on the
screen icon located in your lower right
finally if you have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or you can use the
Q&A button to let us know that you're
having a problem thank you now I'd like
to introduce David shaywitz dr. David Xu
it's the chief medical officer for DNA
Nexus dr. shaywitz is responsible for
driving clinical impact and shaping
company vision working closely with the
DNAnexus team of scientists and
engineers and with external partners and
collaborators most recently at Sarah
bands biopharma he focused on strategy
and business development and led a
product team previously he was a
management consultant at the boston
consulting group working with top five
biopharma clients and co-developing
BCG's internal view on personalized
medicine and before that he was an early
member of the department of experimental
medicine
at merck research labs dr. Shaywitz was
also a founding advisor of sage bio
networks in a co-founder of the mgh MIT
center for assessment technology and
continuous health he graduated summa [ __ ]
laude from Harvard received his MD from
the Harvard MIT division of Health
Science and Technology at Harvard
Medical School and his PhD from the
department of biology at MIT dr.
Shaywitz trained in internal medicine
and endocrinology at the Massachusetts
General Hospital and conducted his
postdoctoral research in Doug Melton's
lab at the Harvard Stem Cell Institute
he currently serves as a visiting
scholar adjunct in the department of
biomedical informatics at Harvard dr.
shaywitz writes regularly about medical
innovation for Forbes and contributes
commentaries to arrange leading
publications please join me in welcoming
dr. Shaywitz I will now turn the
presentation over to him all right
fantastic I can get my slides up here
now great all right hopefully y'all can
I can see this greetings from greetings
from scenic mountain view um I wouldn't
start off on the first I still arc is
going to be about precision medicine and
where we are trying to take a realistic
look at it's sort of what the journey
has been to get here and what are some
of the real issues that we face are
going forward in effort to really what
is it going to take to achieve the
impact that's bringing so many people
together and is going to turn precision
medicine from sort of an over utilized
buzzword just something that can really
inform and improve the lives of patients
I want to start off with a disclosure in
the disclosure section I am an employee
and equity holders shareholder of
DNAnexus a company in Silicon Valley and
then have the adjunct row and Department
medical informatics as you can see all
right so get over here great so I wanted
to start off with a little bit of the
journey and how we how we got to be here
and I wanted to start off with sort of
the error around when the first genome
project project was being contemplated
to take us back to what some of the
mindset and thinking was at this time
when as people started to contemplate to
get the you know to think about the
possibility of being able to to start
imagining sequencing a whole human
genome which seemed like a remarkable
almost unimaginable feet at the time
folks were saying these things like from
City from Sydney Brenner one of the real
Greek geneticist in history he said with
a complete DNA sequence and a big enough
computer you can quote compute the
organism less than a decade later one of
the fathers of sequencing I Wally
Gilbert said with a complete human
genome quote will know what it is to be
unit there was such an outpouring of
excitement of sort of this sort of
almost reductionist orgy of interest in
all of this that um it led to some
people to wonder well jeez are we really
just over hyping what some of the
promises your we just has things gotten
to be a little bit overheated and in
fact there was a really powerful
commentary to Harvard geneticist Richard
Lewington wrote for new york review of
books in 1992 called i dream of genome
where he essentially suggested that our
view of the human genome and this was
his quote from the article essentially
reminded him of a fetish which he did
find is from the Oxford English
Dictionary of course an inanimate object
worshiped by savages on account of its
supposed inherent magical power or is
being animated by a spirit and this
point obviously was people were imbuing
so much power into sort of the DNA
itself and thinking that it was going to
be to the magical answer for everything
that ALB them and nailed humanity and in
fact it's not just DNA for which this is
true when we think about other more
contemporary examples and this is just a
representative sampling but essentially
it could be almost anything that you
might put at the middle of like a
buzzword bingo
part of your the opportunity to select
the space something you know we think
about it maybe in terms of DNA genome
project holy balls are herded for design
designs answer now big data or mobile
and they're these buzzwords that we that
tend to sort of have on the one can
really be powerful but that we tend to
bring this or extra degree of power and
belief and it's real believe it um and
one of the problems of this sort of
these extravagant expectations is that
then there's a predictable reaction so
after there was so much excitement um
from some quarters about what was going
to be the promise which some thought
were going to be maybe the results were
going to be seen more immediately it was
then this reaction where is this I
called a reaction 1 point 0 which was
this service this disappointment we
thought we fought cancer in cancer one
of sharon begley uh always and still is
a top of a game in medical reporting
road for newsweek at the time gina
kolata wrote for The New York Times
advance is elusive and the drive to cure
cancer or another terrific article in
series and um so it was a real both hope
and then sort of almost that the
predictable sort of trough of despair
has it turned out that even once you
were able to sequence the genome things
were still really hard so which brings
us to genomics 2 point 0 which is
essentially introduces at least two new
phenomena the first is the idea of
next-generation sequencing the ability
frankly largely based on on sequencing
instruments from aluminum adults from
other folks in which the cost of
sequencing a genome has gone down
multiple fold I mean an unbelievable
number they say it's sort of happening
faster than sort of Moore's Law is sort
of the expression this is that the left
figure here would be the middle of any
sort of genomics buzzword bingo figure
that's in every paper in every talk but
the idea is that the cost is going down
and the data volume is going up and in
fact there's a really interesting paper
by a group from Illinois and from Cold
Spring Harbor came out last year that
actually talked about the amount of day
being produced and said it may even be
more than the amount of data that's
associated with Twitter with YouTube
with with astronomy they said that we
should have a new term called genomic
which is sort of even more than
astronomical to kind of describe the
massive volumes of data that are
produced and are likely to be produced
from janu from from the next generation
sequencing in the next revision sequin
type of analysis of data so what do you
do about it well um we can look to craig
Venter one of the obviously pioneers
wrong with Eric Lander of the original
human genome effort here's a public and
private effort obviously ventral private
effort and he's now very involved in
several other companies and he testified
before Congress in 2014 and said that
the real key is yes NGS but it's also
the cloud and the ability of the cloud
to manage huge data violence he said the
most important change in the landscape
that he defined or in the computer world
and he said quote the use of the cloud
is the entire future of this field and
obviously we are sure the perspective
and the sort of the if the human genome
project was the expression of genomics
one point node the node miix 2 point 0
perhaps is the expression of it is this
precision precision medicine initiative
which was on privileged to to be at the
White House in each room in 2014 in
January when Obama announced it and it
was it was really exciting the concept
of precision medicine sort of evolved
after personalized medicine there was a
nigha one report written by Susan
desmond-hellmann and others that really
sort of focused on trying to really
utilize more precise measures of
analysis and an individualization to
identify and deliver improved treatment
and the other thing that's incredibly
important about the precision medicine
initiative is a really views the patient
as a partner it sort of it tries to
evolve from kind of a journalistic
history of will work as research is
being done to the patient's reviewed as
a source of data and instead to have
recognized that the patient is a vital
partner
even the driver of the the science that
being done and the ideas that have much
more of an equal shared collaborative
relationship and this is a incredibly
wise approach and it's also driven by
some of the technology and some of the
advances in science and thinking about
you know how you approach an initiative
like this I'm particularly excited by
some of the approaches which we'll talk
about that but developed by a sage bio
networks and folks like John Wilbanks in
terms of how you really apply consent in
a useful and appropriate fashion now
once the human genome project wasn't now
when once pursued the precision medicine
PMI initiative was announced in 2014 it
was and there was a lot of excitement
everywhere you turned with precision
medicine precision medicine precision
medicine and it got very very buzzy I'm
leaving many people many very very smart
people to express concern Michael
Michael joiner from the Mayo wrote am a
very influential op-ed in the New York
I'm saying that Oh moonshot medicine
will let us down Michael melanson a
contributor Fred Forbes and my number of
other world or a thoughtful piece about
the kind of aggressive overly aggressive
use of precision medicine branding in
some diagnostic tests and there were
kind of a number of other articles as
well thoughtful appropriate article that
attempted to contextualise the
excitement around precision medicine and
to say we need to draw a distinction
between the promise which is you know
what why so many of us are excited about
this but to make sure that we do this in
a very grounded way we understand where
we actually are we're the prayer where
we're starting from and not essentially
offer false hope and that will only lead
to sort of further disappoint so when I
would characterize this is to say what
we really need in this field is tangible
impact so I'm using the example of
course of uber not crystal clear not
that we need the uber of anything we're
not looking no one is joining this talk
isn't about trying to be the uber
of healthcare the owner of genomics you
over a Hoover what we're trying to do is
to say one of the things that's so
compelling about Hoover is um really
compelling about it is that you use it
once and immediately get I mean maybe
you try it out because y'all you think
it's trendy you think it's kind of cool
it seems like a new concept but you use
it once and it's like wow this is really
convenient this is how I can get from
place a to place be in an inexpensive
convenient way and you it's intuitively
obvious and once you have the ability to
use it you know you start getting grumpy
when you land in some seen you can't be
here if you don't offer you there it's
not the airport or something like that
it becomes so obvious how it's useful
and then you start to expect it and they
get disappointed when it isn't available
so I would say it's that level of
immediate utility of tangible impact
that precision medicine is aspiring
towards and when you get to the point
where you couldn't the same way that you
sort of were just instinctively most
many of us reach for your uber when you
want to go from place a to place be
similarly you would want to reach you'd
want to demand that a particular on
genetic capabilities and past or present
when it has ethically of immediate over
futility so what I wanted to today the
next do is to go through and to present
um what I would call this Rogers green
shoots some of the early Starnes of
progress some of the signs that I think
reasons to be happy to be hopeful that
we're a progress is being made and we
are moving in the right direction
there's be clear where we're not at the
uber uber level of obvious and gentle
impact for many applications of genetics
but we're getting closer and some so one
area is the area of a family planning in
two areas around this one there's a lot
of use today in the area of carrier
school couples who are matter of
thinking about having a kid will very
often have carrier screening to assess
the potential risk that very a potential
future child make me maybe subjective
and in this presents an example cursive
Council other companies are doing some
little things like that era of a carrier
screening where you're looking at where
in this case a couple word for tested
they were found to both be carriers of
essential recessive gene that if present
in both copies to be it could be
devastating and they actually elected to
have a procedure called preimplantation
genetic diagnostics where you're able to
evaluate in a crazy early stage um cells
and determine and essentially implant
just the just the ones that are don't
carry a homozygous mutation and when
when they did that they may I gave birth
to a healthy baby girl now most folks
are not getting PGD never it's just an
example of a discrete application of
this technology um another example of
just with how fast things are moving in
this space is the non-invasive prenatal
testing so this is when I'm not everyone
undergoes is but many many many pregnant
women alike and couples good you undergo
this they sort of have a screen at
around 10 to 12 ish i think weeks for
the 14 weeks maybe a pregnancy looking
for sort of chromosomal abnormalities
and typically there's first some
screening test often involving
ultrasounds and blood tests and then
historically based on that one would
then if the screening would potentially
worrisome in other the next option is to
have with funny term amniocentesis or
correos in pieces that actually directly
samples of blood samples blood or your
sample cells and amniotic fluid and
evaluates it essentially trying to get a
sense of whether there are particular
chromosomal abnormalities in alien fetus
now because of the new emerging
technologies non-invasive prenatal
testing for example of the line to Tara
and others um yeah one is able to have a
blood test just a peripheral blood test
done
at the early state of pregnancy and if
it's negative a negative is so it's not
definitive but it's essentially better
than the other type of casting that you
can akkad it obviates the need in some
cases to have an amniocentesis or for
you some cases and because they're for
reducing the risk of an accidental
reducing the risk of injury to the fetus
into the mother and frankly saving money
for the further payers which is why come
some payers now are actually paying for
this advanced genetic testing that
really went from initial concept of LPR
lab at Stanford to a implemented test in
a remarkably short amount of time so
another area which we hear so much about
is oncology the idea of that cancer is
you need as a molecular is a molecular
disease it's defined by a range of
malaya of specific mutations and they're
an increasing number of medicines that
target specific mutations and some time
for some types of cancer you sort of
have a sense of what's on your mutation
might being look for it and you can pick
your medicine based on that in some
cases then another case is one of the
things that I'm foundation medicine for
example other company has done is really
been able to sort of finance for some
patients with some type of cancer been
able to identify by using on genetic
testing mutations that one might not
have thought a particular cancer or
might not have immediately thought a
particular cancer might have and by
identifying that mutation suggesting in
not most but in some cases a very novel
form of therapy a drug that might be
usually thought of in cancer a but it
didn't apply this and cancer be and
you're able to do it because you've
identified the particular genetic
mutation and and give the appropriate
therapeutic um this is another example
in a Mendelian genetics fibrosis this is
an incredibly inspiring example this was
on this story heard again at that
precision that is an initial event in
2014 no other was is
at the time the med student I think he's
an intern a resident now um he is a
homeowner who suffered from cystic
fibrosis and he said he but he had a
very specific not the most common form
of mutation for cystic fibrosis a
different kind of mutation a very rare
that only present on four percent of the
patients who have cystic fibrosis but
it's a type of mutation for which there
is a targeted therapy developed by
chemical vertex that is that is
specifically beneficial and proved by
the FDA for patients with this
particular mutation he's appeared to
respond incredibly well was actually on
Michelle Obama's guests if the last
year's State of the Union and when Obama
was talking about in this year at the
precision medicine event apparently he
said that he never expected you know now
he's contemplating being a dad and
grandfather he said things he never
would have contemplated when he was
growing up with Smith cystic fibrosis
but this drug has not only helped with
his help with his breathing help with
this quality of life but also his
trajectory and has really enabled a lot
incredible new opening and the result of
this on targeted treatment here's
another example in the area of
infectious disease and this is a story
are they including the patient's name
that was written about extensively in
the New York Times and other places um
the boy who has a medium so it's
directly no deficiency to sort of
presented with an acute illness of
unknown cause essentially no one knew
what was going on he wound up
essentially a pundit India can do sort
of a medically been in medically induced
coma is this staff on the North Hospital
lantic Lee try to figure out what's
going on with him what what no one knew
what it was they know it once the usual
differential and it didn't come up with
anything that seemed effective kind of
grasping for straws they did this
approach about by Charles chew where he
samples range of fluids and essentially
has a protocol where he looks for
evidence of known infectious agents and
in this case were able to identify a
specific verb for which there's a very
specific
excellent treatment on in this case it's
high dose penicillin the boy is treated
with the medicine and was cured back to
baseline to went from being a pundit
medically induced coma that had everyone
baffled and struggling with what to do
to a specific diagnosis a specific
treatment and a hundred percent
different trajectory on in his life and
in fact work for new Nexus and others
are privileged to on be partnering with
the investigator Charles to at UCSF
blood this effort in a pilot project
funded by on the California precision
medicine initiative trying to take the
methodology used for this and really
blow it out its scale and the DAX of
work between the cloud aspect of it um
so that really these things alice's the
sequencing can be done any of a large
number of places and then analyzed
centrally and again this is really the
brainchild of charles chu and infectious
disease doc UCSF alright so another
example and this is really um really one
of my favorite I find it just an
incredibly inspiring this is this is um
so happy this is uh how do you use on
the meat what you might call the new
genetics in drug development and sort of
the poster child here is his drug ism
target called pcsk9 and it's a lottery
so that the story here is it was a lot
of research but the kind of the the
canonical example or the patient who
sort of represents the story fast is a
woman who in this nature review article
nature article by Steven Holl this new
Jeremy was that just was called out his
named Charlotte Cheryl and Tracy I'm
from Texas in Dallas Heart Study i
believe and she was somebody who was
sent to his healthy mother of two but
who has crazy crazy low LDL but
otherwise i mean n but not nothing else
worry so nothing else just this really
great level of like bad cholesterol
effectively but everything else is fine
and it turned out that she is Miss and
she has kind of lost
function mutations of a mutation in
broad copies of her pcsk9 G so the idea
this is then suggests and this is not
just from the finishers but is an
example of it multiple convergent lines
of a lot of different types of research
from basic translational that
demonstrates if you can even though this
mutation is incredibly rare by the
absence of pcsk9 can be associated with
really low LDL is into a great
cholesterol profile and without doing
any other farm to the person of a
personal able looking fine without any
without any pcs ki have any meaningful
level humping in any level of pcsk9
around ie suggesting pcsk9 might
represent a very good drug chart there's
not been an explosion of interest in
work that tries to look at just these
type of things or tries to find these
sort of rare loss-of-function Newtons
there's been some wonderful work by
their MacArthur to grow it on this and
many others that are really trying to
say can you try to identify these are
rare loss-of-function mutations and gain
insight as um gain insight into
biological processes and in fact the
sort of one of the best example and
again we're at the end and echoes were
privileged to be involved in this really
privileged to be involved in this
because it's just as beautiful very very
well-thought-out effort that represents
a collaboration between incredible
guising of health system when the
project was launched led by steel and
really the genetic comport part solid by
David Ledbetter this remarkable
visionary guy and on the agenda on site
George ankles who's really driving a
research-driven research based on a bio
farma company that he led by a vision
that he's had and it's just exciting to
see this play out for what they're
basically doing is they are sequencing a
whole exome sequencing is called a huge
number of campaigns fully consented
patients in the guising a population the
samples of the identified samples are
sent to guys into Regeneron where the
sequencing is done
all the data are shared from clinical
and genetic data shared narrow eyes on
them on our cloud and internet sorts of
integral integrated interrogated but the
idea is that these data are being able
or being used the boat drive drug
discovery and the sort of trying to find
that pcsk9 type of thing and also used
to provide clinical on input to patients
and also driving clinical research of
the type that Maryland Richie of God
your pen saying guidance in gear um I
think sprin or advising her now are at
the absolute for Fonda and in fact just
as an example of this the general
geisinger collaboration resulting in
work anybody can you know an accessible
work anyone can lead this was a paper a
target identification caper particular
variant associated with them risk for
coronary artery disease that came out
early march in the new england journal
where essentially they were able to gene
their own version of something like the
dallas art fair not quite but it was
essentially they were able to have they
had a question about whether a
particular gene might be doing something
might be involved in coronary artery
disease so they were able to screen
their database for variants that might
be loss of function in this particular
gene they were able to analyze a range
of on clinical endpoints or clinical
parameters which they've also
categorized and i consider elegantly and
then by integrating the data setting up
appropriately setting up the appropriate
controls and essentially running what's
typically a multi-year study at the push
of a button I mean it was more
complicated than that but that's the
basic conceit you're really able to
drive some very interesting work which
then they were able to further validate
using additional in-house technology on
that antibody development technology
that we generalize okay another example
of the power of genetics is um and this
is a really on both the power and I want
to come to as much the limitation of
genetics to this is an example you might
have read about a couple of years ago in
in The New Yorker when an oracle called
one of a kind about a boy who was born
with a condition of unknown clause and
ultimately genetic testing done at the
time I'm a daddy and do identify and end
at I think the ultimate testing was
actually done at gum Baylor identified a
particular mutation that was likely
positive so it turned out that using
clinical exome sequencing such as a
citizen tolerant of other places was
able to it he's relatively easily not
totally relevant easily identify the
causative gene but then identifying a
patient community and learning about it
was far more difficult and we're going
to come back to this important really
social challenge in a little bit so um
halfway mark I maybe I wanted to spend
some time talking about okay that's sort
of where we are two ways one might
contemplate what is to be done so I'm
calling this lens one looking at sort of
this framework and I want to sort of
work through a talking about cushion
full pushing in data and filling out
applications but they roll it up like a
meaningful applications to really sort
of pull the system forward and then
obviously the pivotal role of those
basic science and translation so in
driving the system forwarded urgent need
for really more data on things that are
going to generate more data include
cheaper testing um you know as see Peter
you're going to sequence more patients
if it cost a thousand dollars in if it
costs a million dollars and if the were
to cost a hundred dollars you'd even
sequence more so I think as a cost
continue to drive to have to come down
to be driven down um there's really
going to be more a lot more sequencing
so it's important to recognize that
there the cost of the sequencing itself
but then there also the cost of the
interpretation though that's coming down
as well then the other aspect of more
data is really empowering patients and
it's historically challenging to rest
data from what healthcare organization
biden was talking it on health
datapalooza just this past week about
how unbelievable difficult it was for
him to extract his his his son you
obviously flow or try to
out of cancer and was being treated it
for some naval hospital and ended md
anderson and to get hot of data to move
from one hospital to another even though
his son-in-law he said was like a
leading surgeon and even though he is
vice president of the united states it
was he was he was really just just
beyond and how difficult it was to
actually get the data and even getting
the data you know it's like getting it
on a disk you know sort of like circa
nineteen eighty to actually do so this
is you know the technology is better
than this in every other area and that
not really needs to change and the idea
is that to the extent organizations may
resist releasing data although that's
really changing with some policy the
idea is that if movie data doesn't bond
to organizations as much as to the
patients and to the extent that one can
really prioritize and empower the
patient as the center of this this is
the point violet or Koko's boat the
patient will see you now is the point
the precision medicine initiative where
the goal is to empower the patient is
the product point of that you'll get my
health data movement it's the point of
the past your program that we started on
16 years ago with the idea of our
patients as partners and discovery
within the LCL at Mass General there's
it's really the focus of it is really
recognizing that the locus of ownership
power and control really belongs with
the patient and to the extent that the
system doesn't always operate around
that but really they pay lip service to
a foot to the extent that that really is
true will be better for data movement
and inside generation um next more pull
and this means that that the results
that you get from genetic tests have to
really be as useful and as reliable as
possible and there are lot of aspects to
this I like the ACC e framework which
developed by the CDC you can find on
their website are really nice many nice
post by mu and poetry there really a
terrific thinker in terms of genetics
and public health at the CDC and you
know it is a very helpful framework
where they sort of say well I sort of
the innermost layer first you have to
make sure the first day is for analytic
validity to make sure that you know you
say that there's your test is there's a
chi and
24 but that'd be a tee at position 24
and to make sure that you're calling of
line and this is a lot of the effort of
the precision FDA initiative if I'm
going to get to in a minute again which
we're on privilege to host order to
build importune supported then on the
clinical validity which means that okay
let's say that there is a teeter you say
a team packs and metabolism above your
drug or its associated with a particular
disease well does it you know are you
sure you're right about that you know I
and this is especially interesting in
the context of some recent work very
exciting of the East but one didn't
study i believe from again from
macarthur and comes up a lot I'm doing
to so much amazing stuff this is an
example of work where they sort of look
at a population of folks looking
essentially for these sort of loss of
function from mutations and what they
found to their surprise was and there
are a number of mutations where the
literature had said oh if you have a
particular mutation in this gene you
have a very its associated with a very
very bad consequence you example you
have for sure going to have hearing loss
mutations in this gene oh so you don't
have this particular gene and it doesn't
hurt approaching right you're going to
have a pro you're gonna have here in
well so you're going to have this
problem you're gonna have that problem
and then they found all these examples
in this population where that didn't
happen it turns out that while the
initial folks who were studied maybe
they were all in one particular
population where people that mutation
was associated with hearing loss turns
out in another population well it wasn't
in fact that people seem to hear just
fine so it's really important that one
sort of gets this right and that in
particular you can imagine and again um
hi Rima talk about this in a really nice
ahead young Atlantic article in a really
poignant story about how you know
telling someone that a particular
mutation that was identified I think if
prenatal testing was she go though it's
you know if the data suggests it's it's
harmful um they on the couple of unity
terminated the pregnancy and then she
comes back kind of running back after
the fact in a couple of weeks saying oh
there are some new data it turns out
it's not a bad mutation it may be fine
but it was sort of chi late so that's
sort of a pretty sobering and again it
you know
what a youngster in the Atlantic it's a
another terrible a signal article and
then finally um there's a new
improvements in clinical utility and
let's say you know you accurately say
your mutation here and this is
associated with metabolism of warfarin
boom we know that show what you still
pay for the test is it still make a
difference can you do anything with the
result and there is a healthy debate
here about what does the word actionable
mean in some cases you can say all
knowledge is actionable it's informed
that it's good to know knowledge is good
to know there's an from the perspective
of a payer they're like you know for
example the specific question the case
of war from your the blood thinner with
rat poison um do you use or should you
test work for you if you're going to
start someone on you can't I coagulate
someone is it better to start them on if
you just pick a random dose or do you
try to have a pic your initial dose
informed by the metabolism and you think
well my goodness if there's a thinking
of the component which there is
unarguably clinical validity is there
let's know you should test it but when
they've done randomized controlled
studies of this it's really hard to find
any meaningful impact of doing actually
doing the genetic test because
clinically could one to Jake very
genetics only countless or half the
variability and there's a whole other
component where in any case you're going
to want to go slow go low and go slow
which is how you start people I work for
it and you're going to want to do that
in many cases so even though there is
genetics and they're always reading all
these like statistics we're always
putting about how many drugs have a
genetic component the real question is
how does that knowledge meaningfully
impact what you're going to do
clinically and there are some real
instances where it shouldn't mean
they're subjective leaned ot can wear or
it has a genetically related um impact
user GI impact that are completely
dependent on whether you have won you
won from a gene or another and I you
know now it's more like if someone has
it side of like like oh maybe we
shouldn't give you the drug but
obviously if you could someone shows up
with the phenotype with the genetics and
hand it becomes immediately unethical to
give them a drug that you know they're
going to respond for Lincoln and there
are other examples of that as well um
this is just reminding here of the
pivotal critical underlying role of
basic science of curiosity inspired
research obviously under Dusty
apples were seeing every we're seeing of
this is christopher crisper us or the
pioneering technology of his gene
editing technology and it was discovered
from basic basic science people were
exploring how bacteria protect
themselves from viruses and in the
course of it they discovered this enzyme
that turned out to have additional uses
and so it's obviously this is incredibly
the pivotal role in driving this and
there's also an essential to increase
the rate of knowledge turns and we're
going to come chin cut in a minute ah
and then it is issue of them for more
translation and this has been sort of
something I have been really focused on
I think my whole life this it's running
often underappreciated child turn it's
this science doesn't generally find its
way into practice without deliberate
effort it's sort of like the underpants
known problem of South Park you know
step one make a lab discovery step two
step three clinical and you know there's
this kind of step two in there that
often get some underappreciated and so
there's a real really important role for
how does that translation happen and how
can it be accelerated non-trivial is
somewhat of an understatement um and I
think that the three elements that I
would really call out of being
critically important election in try to
focus our there's a vital role in
driving translation I've engaged patient
participants in gated participants
nations who are driving or urging to
science or say neat you know who are
very engaging everything you really need
to pull this forward to make sure what
the assigned stage doesn't just stay in
the lab and really charger driven by the
clinical urgency next in the role of
frontline providers or the physicians
and caretakers or who are seeing what
the actual clinical needs are who are
recognizing the limitations of and any
end up and the capabilities of existing
treatments and who often have the most
astute insights into sort of what might
be needed what are some of the issues
and can really play a particular role in
driving science forward and I like you
really role models you're like Einar
Sawyer of UCSF who I think it is written
and described more elegant than anyone i
know that power and importance of flood
line providers
and then finally and I know I sort of
kind of harp on this at length but I
really see a sort of health care
entrepreneurship is the raw experience
of translation I think this is
fundamentally what entreprenuer
entrepreneurs do is driving the promise
of science of science into something
that's actually I'm robust enough to to
give to patients and to be able to do
not the only ones by any means and it
really you need everybody but I think in
terms of the conversations I've had in
the folks who are most intent who are
let's say just intensely focus on this
very specific problem of how do you get
some that seems promising but often is a
little bit fragile how do you drive that
to actual application and I think this
is why there's such an important role
for entrepreneurs in the oven health
care in the life sciences so I want to
take this a minute or two to look at
what look at this through what one mic
one might call lens too well the
consulting background there everything
has to have a lens so and this is sort
of the idea of data of data sharing it
has really been in the news lately with
the concept of data parasites data
sharing data silos all of these all of
these things it's really clear that um
everybody's really focused on that Obama
talk again incredibly articulately about
the challenges I didn't park very
pointedly about it um huge efforts from
a Republican leadership in the Senate
and in the house to really bipartisan
efforts on in Congress be fair driving
the focus on data share and
interoperability everyone recognizes
that this ISM that this is a good and if
this is a new important to accelerate
though how to do it is unavailable
billing the cat problem so data sharing
and again most talks after you know the
same way most genetic stock have the
cost of sequencing going down most data
sharing talks either use the power of
Babel of metaphor on the left or the
data silo on metaphor on the right and
it's sort of unfortunate that these are
the two of two choices what I wanted to
produce
is an example this is course and don't
something you know that this is math
isn't actually how it works i know that
but at a very you know directionally
correct navy level just to just sort of
highlighting the value of networks
versus sort of silos and the idea is
that the value of a network is reporting
to the square of the nose so and again I
mean this is arithmetic my children can
do but the idea is that as you go and
you know as you have more and more nodes
the data loss that you have the the
difference between the difference
between here and here is essentially two
different the cost of not sharing that's
what some so profound um so some of the
really inspiration for this I take from
us josh summer who I was privileged
enough to listen to at the first sage
bio network at sage bar networks of
identity of a founding advisor that one
by John John I was founded by Stephen
friend and our chat and release focuses
on data sharing and approaches for for
rich I inspired data sharing and open
science on the first conference that
they had a incredible speaker josh
summer who I was when the undergraduate
at Duke he was diagnosed with the way of
cancer for DOMA and then he sort of a
can recover unfortunately with again
with a lot of support in his mom as a
physician at all I'm in a new to the
point where in 2014 easy on forbes 30
under 30 leader very very well earned
much deserved but he really talked about
the urgent need to share data and how
unbelievable unbelievably frustrated he
was trying to get academics working on
core DOMA to share data with each other
so Biden would be surprised a lot of
people may have been um the UM this is
all you know the lady Andrew Grover's
also incredibly inspiring I mean he
wrote about this kind gentleman 2005 and
you know I had several discussions with
him and he really would really sort of
highlight at this point that they cry
you trying to figure out how come
industries like technology like
microchips in two weeks ago you'll
generate so much progress so fast and
why isn't why here to in health care
obviously it's complex the multiple
differences but he thought that it could
really be boiled down to the different
disparate weight of knowledge terms
between the two industries and and he
said knowledge turns if she defines the
indicator the time it takes to go from
the hypothesis to result and then you
develop a new hypothesis and basically
it it just takes so long because of the
degree of data of data for tea and just
the reluctance of an enemy was referring
to academic investigators and untrue
plasterboard to richly share data with
each other even though human lives are
at stake um and in fact come back to the
case again Matt might who I'm not the
guy in effective amid the inspiration
whoo-hoo in order to once he had the
identification of the notation for his
that his childhood NGO 11 mutation when
he wanted to try to find other patients
that the science community wasn't as
helpful as the really true dense
networks that you had from more
traditional social communities like
Google and reddit and basically from
writing a blog and in a way to sort of
set up to generate a lot of hits that
was we weren't on Reddit and other
social media sites that's actually what
in his case generated the leads that was
able to help them find other families
there's a kind of a robust I make sure I
get to everything goes a robust debate
now about whether the problem of data
sharing is that essentially it's not in
the economic self-interest of folks to
share data as some have argued or if
it's just they don't really have the
capabilities or experiences or the
governance to be able to do that and
there's an interesting perspective on
that knee had elements of flow um my two
cents on this is that I think medicine
the one hand is intrinsically
conservative mosy cautious and sort of
change but I think as an incredibly deep
seeded commitment to doing right by
patients and the way I mean is you can
serve gather theme of this talk is that
I think you know people are convinced by
proof but that as the benefits of
sharing the harms of siloing become
increasingly concrete become palpable
come to the point where it's so overtly
you know like the same way like denying
someone like a vaccine would be
unethical did you
give them a vacuum something I suspect
you don't give in venison happy when you
think of doing that similarly if and
when we get to the point I imagine when
we're um you know the ideas once it
becomes so clear that everyone benefits
from this will brush sharing I think
we'll get to the point where it gets a
point it becomes unimaginable not to do
it again provide a convenient be done in
an appropriately consented safe and
secure fashion which is an important
qualifier holistic um i wanted i think i
may have a perspective on this that may
be informed by again at DNAnexus we've
had really had a privilege of a point of
being the platform that helped bring so
many different teams so many different
investigators and data and science
together that we've really seen
incredible and personally I've seen just
the power of collaboration in a robust a
data sharing what happens when you bring
the researchers and data and tools all
together in a common place in this case
on the cloud so there's a number of
these consortiums on encode and chard
and I sponsored a general and guiding
your example i just discussed and then
precision fda and i'm just going to give
you had a minute or two on a couple of
these the encode consortium is a
consortium that's designed to
essentially develop and to characterize
it looks hard stress before the sort of
functional units of a sort of
functionally important of DNA and so the
regulatory elements and in a range of
other elements of sort of a part of the
genome and a range of investigators
mostly in the US the key design features
of this which I think are relate to the
fact that it's been so effective is that
there's a central court in this case
this isn't the only way to do it in fact
we've worked with a number of different
approaches so it's trying to share
examples of things that have worked one
is the idea of a central portal world so
the data is received and they are on
subject to vary on that essentially in
order to be my understanding of this is
that for the further the investigators
were involved we're contributing the
project to be essentially fully
reimbursed by the government on their
glands they actually have to submit the
day they submit has to pass
a predefined quality control oh and also
has to utilize very specific
vocabularies and ontology so that you
can everything can be classified in the
standardized fashion and I think that's
been critical to the success and equally
critical maybe even more so is the role
of data provenance and process
transparency even if people say they're
doing a similar thing you have to
actually know what how data were
analyzed and be able to track the
provenance of each piece of data and
have very defined pipelines but this
shows a kind of metadata that was cuz
that's collected and associated with
each of the bits of sample and encode
and in this sort of highlights the
employment in these slides are all
courtesy of P I of the encode data for
tanks and a Mike cherry of Stanford
amazing investigative is a role of not
having a black box pipeline but update
on the other hand being able to
understand exactly what's involved and
being able to track each of the
individual steps and be able to say this
piece of data came from here can from
here came from here and be able to track
it an incredibly granular on an
ascension in a mutable fashion which is
of course exactly what our pipeline what
are our platform enables um the other
example I want to get to is on precision
FDA which is a community platform for
NGS assay evaluation develop really the
brainchild of one of the most brilliant
people I've ever been privileged
encounter and government doctorate aha
cartoon just its senses is like
unbelievable visionary person who start
off with the CDC didn't bunch of amazing
stuff there then came the FDA where he
had an open and he served about the
conduct of open FDA he sort of a total
with Stephen Colbert my calling it get
her just understand data understand sort
of the how it moved how its structured
one of the challenges and is also able
to get stuff done and in and just
incredibly inspired way anyway he had
this idea of building this community
platform referred to be selected to
build it I in conjunction with them we
were able to actually build it from the
initial kroger written in something like
the beginning of September we were in
beta for the community by
and in something like three months is an
unbelievable accomplishment it shows how
agile development can work this is or
the splash page demonstrates in the
range of capabilities available on
precision FDA where you can upload files
you can run comparisons this is or what
the ecosystem looks like where people
come you know each organization can have
a look it has access to a private area
for data sharing area note that the FDA
is not in anyone's private area they
were interestingly during the design
process even more insistent on that then
you might have you know there are many a
lot of people externally are like oh the
update wants to climb a private data I
turned out that's the last thing they
wanted to do when they wanted to not
have anything to do with anyone private
data but just data that was explicitly
shared in the community here um this
demonstrates a rapid global growth of
the community that now has and again
thanks to FDA put a slide over 500
organizations and over a thousand
members on this for example the range of
apps that are on the application I can
see I'm getting low on time the cuts of
comparisons you can run against on
provisional or benchmarks and then what
they've also done is set up these
community challenges if you're actually
on the second one is for those
consistency challenging foods challenge
has now been launched we're really the
community so essentially completes and
submits results before the results are
known in some cases come in set the case
of the second challenge and tries to see
how well they're approaching and again
this is not for regulatory purposes it's
for a sort of process development at the
moment come and this is er demonstrates
the value of a community so this is um
sort of discussion area and so data and
to the submission area within me you
know one of these challenges and you can
just see the incredible broad community
participation from folks at the road
from company sanity Roche um Garvin and
Australia UC Santa Cruz I mean just in
credits so there's an incredible broad
range of interest in essentially this is
an example of when you build it and if
you do it nicely how people will come in
people are engaged um so couple of
removing the last five minutes here a
couple of kind of final words
my own thoughts and all the data sharing
stuff is I think it's really good to
have a problem use case in mind to
understand what you're solving for
versus sort of boiling the ocean I think
the general is really one of the best
examples of this that I've seen they
really had this incredible vision
McKenna with again it's been an
incredible privilege here to work with
people we tend to serve work with other
people who have the vision the sort of a
couple of years ahead and say aren't
learn well let's listen else to it first
and if it's okay what kind of you know
you know crawling after them these are
people who have a big George ain't got
one man has a vision this is how we
really can see drug discovery working
and pursued it um with folks like
incredibly firing folks like Jeff lead
and others I would general and this is
an example of how it can really work um
too they had a very specific idea of how
they were going to use it just like
outline that new england journal papers
a matter of fact you know for the world
to see and it's really exciting to see
it work in practice and there i think
they're at something around 100,000
whole exome sequences and going for 250
i think george said 500 may be only a
matter of time before they decide to go
for a million and given the efficiency
and focus they are likely to get there
um you know very rapid they I think it's
important how to bias to action versus
sort of endless recursive contemplation
and top-down strategizing I think you
can go crazy with having endless
meetings I mean the means that this is
is top-down view because the world is
going to change they're all these things
are going to discover once you start to
develop these and so I think you have to
have the critical guardrails in place of
security and compliance which is
obviously for the girl platform in place
but then recognize it how the ability to
adjust versus you know sort of stick to
some plan that he developed before you
really knew as much as you need to know
perfect is being the enemy of the good
and again it's incredibly powerful to
bring data people and tools together I
know when given the opportunity to
collaborate people really like to do it
okay last couple of minutes here really
one of the most important topics is that
that it's important as technology is in
achieving the promise of precision
medicine realization was all about
impassioned champions innovation is
driven by champions repeat them
innovation is driven by champions this
is true in drug development is a great
flowers in
elman paper where's it at anybody new
virtual e beverly every drug they could
identify me did i get one point had some
reason very good reason possibly kill a
total development but it made it through
because of the clinical champion someone
who championed the program um i was
really inspired by talk from I'm glad
Judah Folkman they gave where he said
innovation are driven by inquisitive
physicians inquisitive researchers now
I'm sure would add inquisitive data
scientists I would say if when I
described what our platform does is an
example it is to empower it's not to
solve people's problems it's to empower
those inquisitive physicians researchers
and data scientists to unleash their
imaginations and impassioned into let
loose on the data and to really make
progress and of course there's all kind
of everything this Margaret need which I
really love I never doubt that a small
group of thoughtful committed citizens
can change the world the only thing that
as ever that ever has and serve my final
slide here which is just an example of
all the different precision medicine
champions I feel like me if I'm just
sort of representative example there
many others I could have picked here on
a research the the folks on the Left who
were really incredibly sharp NT and
jigna on who are incredibly important in
econ elucidation of a crisper patient
champions like Gotham like not light and
his family as we discuss data championed
like a Regina holiday and if anything
figured sugar on cam is you probably
have seen her jackets and walking
gallery clinical champions like alison
has generally clinical oncologist who is
a deep knowledge of science and actions
of patients really if they've allowed to
deliver high quality mr. precision as
inspired care doctor Taha cartoon
unbelievable um inspirational figure um
fine government at the FDA a
collaboration champion such as a Steven
friend and John will banks and they're
on incredibly important world at stage
by all networks there are some words
that they have done it not only in terms
of rivet allowing people to collaborate
and work together but also in terms of
I think the work that they've done on
somebody collaboration with Apple but in
particularly in terms of patient consent
and in really making it possible to get
to go from the fact that patients
deserve to see the data their own data
to making it actually happen and I
really can't speak highly enough of the
of some of the efforts of this group
although if you want to hear more about
John Lowe bank you can listen to the
tektronix podcast which we interviewed
him on it last year and then finally
translational champions on many examples
I'm especially fond of the work and the
thinking of Susan desmond-hellmann I
might have also added a to a beaut here
folks who really appreciate the
challenges of translation and the
importance of having the very best
people work together on the challenges
of bringing together leaders from
academia and Industry and instead of
focusing on difference in saying oh
you're not in your nature your undoing
this realize that these are unbelievably
difficult problems that we're facing in
order to cure disease in order to make
impacts again complex challenging
difficult problems the only way on the
planet to solve this is going to be by
getting the very best people to work
together and toward toward solutions
hopefully you'll be wondering if you're
listening your warranty will be one of
the precision medicine champions as well
I'm really grateful for your time and
listen what fight Sen way of questions
come so far other other questions that
come up now there's sort of a more
detailed question that maybe I would
answer offline any other questions that
i can answer or judy should I wrap up
what do you think have a good
thank you dr. Shaywitz for that
informative presentation it is time for
Q&A so if you have a question you'd like
to ask dr. shaywitz please do so now
just click on the green to an a button
at the lower left of the presentation
window type your question into the box
that appears on your screen and click on
the send button and a question that
commits has come in that Thank You
Phyllis to is too technical for the
general audience dr. Shaywitz will
perhaps you could answer that on a
one-on-one basis as we're almost out of
town out of time I'm thinking that
Gandalf shields would like to thank you
for your presentation and wonder it just
a few have any final comments you'd like
to share with us that's been me I guess
I really most strong believer and
grounded optimism I think that people
given half a chance you know that it you
know the extent that we can you know
sort of realistic you know that we are
able to empower patients that we were
able to share data a lot of these things
sort of sound like feel good buzz words
but i think you know when you start when
you're face-to-face with the patient has
it your condition is really trying to
you know the way that it's so hard it
for patients with rotated i mean i think
it's as particularly poignant in
oncology where it seems so hard not to
have nominal data sharing relationships
but the amount of information that gets
left on a table from from in it from
even an individual clinical encounter to
shoot you like if you don't if someone
comes into clinic and you're not able to
known as i know what you you know the
first time you see them it's already
unfortunate but then if someone comes
into a different year to your physician
is across the hall from you and they've
not been able to learn from what the
first perform what your experiences with
your first nation that really starts
becoming excusable and has that sort of
multiplies there's so much opportunity
for this what data there left on the
table and opportunities for learning i
think we really owe it to our patients
to really capture and two and get into
it I'm integrated as much data as we can
she got a really learn what we can and
to bring it from together with empathy
and understanding and really try to
improve the care of it so we do we do
have another question for you possibly a
couple more general questions how is the
participation of the regulatory and
control in a team I'm not sure you know
something I how is a participation of
the regulatory and conformity you know
to be honest with you I don't understand
the question but maybe if whoever wrote
it is able to email it to you so the
question is how is the participation of
the regulatory control any team I don't
understand question so but if someone
maybe she and she's going to be quite
but if she writes in more detail or he
I'll being able to have it all for more
detailed response
yes the remaining questions that would
be great if you would respond via email
we will now be opening the DNAnexus
website on your screen this will open in
another browser or tab on your computer
this is an educational webinar and thus
offers free continuing education credits
after the webinar is over and to get
your credits click on the button located
in the bottom left hand corner of your
web page before I go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through November 12 2016 you'll receive
an email from labyrinth letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon goodbye